hello Conan O'Brien here I've still got
the beard and now a pretty crappy office
I have an important message for you and
that's this for months I've been
bombarded with calls from the media
demanding to know the name of my new
show
Conan what's the name of your new show
what's the name of your new show I'm
father the bride then maybe the pizza
pie and I make the nothing to know the
new show that was one Italian guy wanted
to know it's good pizza anywho they want
to know I've got the answer I've spent
millions of dollars I've had media
research companies we've had thousands
of people working around the clock and
we have got it drumroll please a burner
it's more of a cat purring sorry and
bang there it is Tony simple pure like
the man himself and actually this end
looks like a W kkona kkona coming on CBS
I have to stick with that now because
we're only doing one take of this thing
so starting December 8th no it's
December they said this just November of
this year yes not good no set okay
anyway that's the name of the show here
it is it's on TBS uh-huh November are
you sure okay November 8th copy right
there you go I got a lot of work to do
so what so it's gonna be great put that
sandwich down Kona coming this fall to
TBS